did i see an interview where you
mentioned that one of the
ideas behind the us
enabling chinese trade was that by
raising living standards and by raising
uh bringing their population out of
poverty the presumption is that um
democracy kind of comes along for the
ride that you have this educated
populace
they have better living standards and
then they start to once they've got food
and water and heat and shelter they
start to look at these bigger questions
uh but what perhaps we hadn't accounted
for was the power of a very
authoritarian regime with technology to
uh deploy its means
yeah that's exactly right there were
people like tom carruthers and others
who certainly in the in the later mid to
later 90s were making this argument that
once people get to be around have around
seven thousand dollars in annual income
they start to make demands and it forces
governments to change to meet the
demands of those empowered public
and in my mind it's a little bit of the
arrogance on our side to feel and it was
the same thing with the francis fukuyama
argument about the end of history
they just assumed that there's just one
path and we know it and we're on it and
we had that kind of
arrogance and and frankly that arrogance
hurt us because we thought well all we
need to do is help china get rich we
just need to open our systems
and we just need to have an open
internet
and then the pull the structural pull of
all these is going to be so
transformative that there's nothing that
the chinese government can do bill
clinton had a famous
line we talked about the chinese
internet he's trying to control the
internet he's trying to nail jello to
the wall good luck with that well
china's nailed jello to the wall they've
done actually a great job they've
they've gotten rich
their average income is is above that
level uh and they they are they are
pioneering just a different model of
organization and in many ways it's
working
in some ways for the people who are
living in china as i mentioned
different estimates 700 million people
brought out of abject poverty we talk
about realizing the sustainable
development goals most of that work has
just been done by china not because the
united nations declared these standards
or jeffrey sachs
helped think them up
because the chinese government for its
own purposes
was doing what it wanted to do to
improve
the the well-being and status of china
and the people in in
in china so
um it was it was almost an arrogant view
on our side um and then but but so i
don't think that democracy liberal
democracy
is in any way inevitable but if we
believe in it if we believe in the
rules-based international order um we
need to think about well how do we grow
it how do we grow it in an inclusive way
and again i'm i'm
american
and i'm certainly a
patriotic in my way
american but
that doesn't mean that i think america
has done everything right we certainly
did a great job of helping
win two world wars and and organize the
world after the after the second and
defended uh the free world for a long
time but massive flaws massive
shortcomings
massive selfishness in terms of our our
use of natural natural resources and
there's a lot to criticize
on all sides um and i think we need to
we need to do that and we need to
articulate what's the kind of world that
would like to live in
and then try to to build the best path
from here to there
here's the thing man
it may end up being
that a modern society
really struggles to flourish under a
democracy
that the i think about this all the time
that the principles of freedom
genuinely might be some sort of old and
worldly harkback thing that is really
really challenging to wrangle when you
have technology and ubiquitous
communication and all this sort of stuff
now i don't disagree that it makes for a
more flourishing life i think that that
is how you can maximize
a human's uh
enjoyment of their days
but we're not talking about that here
we're not talking about enjoyment we're
talking about effectiveness and it may
end up being that an authoritarian
regime like the ccp
is so much more effective
that
without correct checks and balances
without correct sanctions without
correct um foresight and long-term
planning
that
it
they're so much more effective that you
can't compete with them with a
freedom-based society you know i mean
all of the time that's been spent with
political infighting in divisions in the
u.s if all of that had been put toward
moving in one direction as a unified
front and going together
imagine how much more progress we would
have made now the problem that we have
is because it's a democracy and because
people have freedom they are free to
disagree which causes people to take one
step forward and one step back as
opposed to in china where if you want to
disagree just go do forced labor like
you're you're just unpersoned for a
while and that means that everybody is
moving in the same direction so
yeah that that really concerns me the
fact that
freedom may be fundamentally
incompatible with a modern
technologically advanced world when you
have a
ccp like party there competing on a
global scale
yeah so
democracy
is not an end in itself it's a means to
the end
of good and accountable governance and
it's got to to deliver and certainly the
argument uh that you just made we've
heard it before people were making that
argument with the united states and the
soviet union and especially in the early
years how can we compete when they're
all on the same line they're moving in
the same direction with north and south
korea in the early days
north korea was it was developing faster
than south korea and people were in
south korea were saying how can we
flourish with
with democracy so people have
made that argument repeatedly and
economically uh when japan was taking
off and they had their famous uh midi
ministry of industry and and technology
people were saying well how can we with
our our messier
economy uh compete with japan and in all
of those cases uh democracy and open
society flourish and i still believe in
in open societies but that doesn't mean
and connected to biasing before
now that that that that success
is predetermined we've got to make it
happen and we've got to make sure
that our open societies are able to
deliver and that when we talk about open
societies they really are open societies
and that's why we need to make sure at
least here in the united states that our
democracy functions and that's also why
it concerns me so much when i see that
elements of the republican party for
example um
seem to have a strategy of
disenfranchisement of kind of trying to
reduce the electorate
in order to achieve a different goal and
i'm sure there will be listeners to this
podcast who disagree with that
but
we need to make sure our democracy works
we need to make sure that people feel it
works and we need to make sure that it's
that it's delivering i talked about
china bringing 700 million people out of
abject poverty we don't have 700 million
people here in the united states
we have a lot of people who are living
in abject poverty we have a lot of
people whose life prospects are way less
than other people and we can't afford to
throw people away
there are people now who are being born
in terrible situations slums
who have the potential to be mozart's
and einsteins and john von neumann's and
isaac newton's whatever whatever
whatever you want
but we're not allowing those people the
opportunity to contribute in the ways
that we need them to so i i know open
societies can and hopefully will win in
the end but it's not on autopilot every
person has a role to play in realizing
that future what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace